yes I know I'm later than usual with
this review but I had a really busy
weekend where amongst other things I
picked up this thin ice so I'm going to
say up front I really really thought
this was going to be the Ice Warriors
episode just based off title it I'd gone
out of my way to avoid watching any of
the preview stuff to get more of a sense
of it so so these price have that not be
the case overall thoughts in the episode
I like it it's pretty good it's it's not
exactly what I was asking for of ahead
of this episode my invade thing was like
can we get to lane with a more intricate
plot you know because we've had a couple
in a row that were fairly basic plots
focus on the dynamical bill on the
doctor more whoo sorry about that so um
what we got here was again a pretty
straightforward plot yes
oddly that didn't annoy me I would have
thought that they would have done but it
didn't I think part of that has to do
with just how much I really really am
enjoying the dynamic between the doctor
and bill which is wonderful for me
because I was so certain I wasn't gonna
like bill I didn't like any of the early
previous stuff that we saw her in so I'm
digging the heck out of their dynamic I
like this sort of Tudor kind of role he
takes with her where he you know they
have their banter and they had their
back and forth but he takes the teaching
moments for lack of a better term like
the whole sort of you know I'm doing
this on your command I'm sure there are
people out there have been like the
doctor doesn't always listen to the
commands like that was like no but he's
teaching her he's pushing her to get her
to learn things to get her to broaden
her experience to get her to take
command and I'm just I'm liking this
dynamic I'm liking that he's with
somebody who he he's pushing
deliberately I mean we had Clower for so
long in you oh she was just she was a
mystery to him for a while and she kept
pushing him and that's not that I'm
against somebody sort of pushing the
doctor in a direction
it's nice to see that you know back to
him really wanting to push her into new
experiences into new perspectives and
new ideas and that's that's what I'm
getting from this relationship between
them and I like it a lot now as far as
the plot of this thing goes it bears
more than a passing resemblance to the
Beast below so again that should bug me
Audrey it doesn't I think the change in
setting does a lot to sort of take the
curse off reusing the basic plot of
giant you know trapped creature being
used for something that it doesn't want
to be part of so I think the setting is
nice which again surprises me because a
lot of the past earth setting was I I
don't care for some of them I I don't
really like it all but that worked for
me I and and you know the suddenness of
that boy they the boy died that kind of
caught me off guard and I likely wasn't
done kattiline that the proper weight of
the impact that especially on Bill was
given and like it really kind of snapped
her out of this then again I'm I'm just
liking how she's taking on this end that
she's asking the questions that somebody
like like me or because of people who
tend to watch the show would ask you
know is it okay for me to touch stuff is
this going to screw everything up and
the way the doctor sort of messes with
her a little and plays off that I like
that the villain is just a human which
again paralleling the Beast below it
maybe I should have called that because
that was the case there too but I liked
it it's just no humans can be awful and
it's not even a case of like he's a
human working for the aliens no on his
own completed up to his own devices this
is a horrible human being that happens
so I like that a what it was a
not-so-subtle dig you know at sort of
capitalism and you know industry and I
am a job creator didn't use those terms
but they might as well have and so
therefore my life counts for Morin it
wasn't subtle but if it works and it
works with sort of the driving
philosophy of the doctor as a person a
doctor who's a show so that all works
for me I really am
we can get a nardole you know back into
things now that you apparently lost the
coin toss because I am missing him a
little bit I've gotten you know
definitely to solid episode that's just
so the doctor and I think that dynamic
now can we get Naruto integrated in so I
can see how all three of them are going
to be together that would be nice
that's sort of my big hope for the next
episode um and and you know we got a
little bit of the vault it was a knock
from the inside so obviously whatever
then there is sentient it is alive so
it's not just a piece of equipment or
something else I don't think that's a
huge shock I think most folks would have
figured it was a person or being of some
kind the very obvious thing for it to be
would be the master Johnson master in
particular because I mean the you know
the knocking that that ties back to the
master and and his appearance has the
master specifically that almost seems
too obvious and I'm kind of inclined to
say that's not going to be the case if
it does turn up being the case though
I'm going to be annoyed that that we
already knew Johnson was coming back
because if that is him behind that bolt
and if he had just shown up that would
have been a pool but and so I don't
again I hope not because it's too
obvious I'd like ask whatever is behind
that vault vault vault vault I would
like to be surprised by I'm not sure if
there is too much more to say it was
just it was just a lot of nice little
moments that I enjoyed of you know a lot
of lines that I liked a lot of bits of
banter I enjoyed a lot of just moments
for the doctor moments for Bill I could
go through them systematically but
really this was a fun episode and I
enjoyed it a lot it wasn't phenomenal
like I said the plot is really basic the
focus is really still on the characters
but right now the characters are working
so well that's not a bad thing if we
don't start getting some more involved
more intricate unusual or surprising
plots it might become a bad thing but so
far for me at least it's holding
pretty well just focusing on the doctor
and Bill and and how they work as a team
and like I said just a lot of little
moments little things I had a lot of
points where I was smiling at a lot of
points where I basically went haha and
just it's a very enjoyable episode I
think enjoyable is the best possible
term not necessarily in a disposable way
but not in a way that really demands a
ton of discussions I have a feeling this
is probably going to run a little bit
shorter than my reviews have of late
because the stuff that has been working
is still working and working really well
and I'm still enjoying it
so we'll see where things go from here
like I said I'd like to see nardole get
reintegrated into the group I think
we'll probably get that now that you
know he kind of you know he lost the
coin toss and I like that whole thing
where the doctor just wants to know how
this con man did this trick coin flip
that's that just feels very much him
like oh it's a chance for me to learn
something new that doesn't happen often
and that he got excited by that I mean
that's just cool so I mean that's kind
of a hope for me like I do want the
stories to start getting a little bit
more intricate a little more twisty or
surprising I'd like that to happen soon
I'm not given how much I enjoyed this
episode I'm not going to say I need it
to happen next episode if they want to
bum around for one more go and if the
dynamic can be as fun as this is you
know what I'll be good for that for one
more time but I guess that's about it
for my thoughts on Vinay
have you seen it hope so I talks about
get a knock spoilers I don't know like I
said it wasn't like a who get into the
plot kind of story maybe I didn't say
much of the last worlders in any case
did you see it what were your thoughts
on whatever they were drop something
down in the comments and let's talk
about it don't forget to like subscribe
check me out on Twitter at Council of
geeks give us into the council of geeks
podcast as well as the punch like a girl
podcast available to different podcast
feeds on both iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]